here we are about 15 million years before our modern era the last ice age is over and it's
getting warmer now all these immense glaciers that cover most of north america are going to
melt away and all that water is going to raise the sea level all the continents will change shape
until they look the way they do today and as for mankind well after a long and very hard migration
across siberia people arrive here in what we call montana before long brighter horizons will open
Look!
For the others.
But are they good to eat?
A maestro, he'll tell us that.
Come in.
Huh?
He's earned some.
What's that?
Then you tell me if they elect a sick man.
Some nice ones, some big ones, some bad ones.
Over there.
One thing that we don't.
I'm not surprised you find them everywhere.
We had better move off and leave it to them.
It's not worth fighting for.
Let them have it.
This way, they went on for generations,
migrating, spreading out all across the Great Plains
as far as Nevada.
On to the Great Lakes.
Then to the forest of the eastern seaboard.
A few centuries later, our friends find themselves in the south.
New Mexico, near Clovis.
One thing you can come up with a little invention.
I'm pretty sure with this your spear will have much greater power.
I'll show you.
It might be just what I need.
Considered pretty good, right?
But I can throw mine farther.
Likely, I'm a lot stronger.
All right, let's say it's a match of brain against brawn.
Well, you go first, over there.
Throw as far as you can.
Hmm.
That.
Yes, you did it all right.
You used that thing.
That's why yours went further.
This is what did it.
You get much greater power.
With this, we can kill larger animals.
Now we won't miss 'em.
I'll show you.
You'll see.
Your turn, Chief.
It's always my turn.
You're so small, no one will see you.
He's always got some kind of good reason.
I'll show you, Chief.
So how he did it?
Interesting gadget that you two have, man.
It's really great for hunting any animal we want,
but we have to make lots of them.
Let's get rid of it.
It'll be quite a good dinner, then.
We didn't kill any animals. We are all starving.
You have killed many delicious animals.
Welcome to our meal. There's enough for all.
It's a very good spearhead, either.
What do you say we trade this one for yours?
You want to trade spears? All right. Here.
This one here, and you give me yours.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'd rather keep mine.
mind. Your friend is no fool. The Clovis head is an efficient weapon. Oh yes, it was the
finest in its time, but it took time to make one and a great skill. We want to go back
and make big animals over there. We see many beautiful horses over there. We have a good
supply of meat. There's no point in killing more animals. Whenever we see them, we hunt
them. We like them. Yes, but if you go and kill too many animals, there won't be any
for our children. What do we care about that? Now we've got good spearheads, we'll use
Kill as many as we can.
What's the good of killing just to kill?
The animals are our friends, just like trees that give us shade in the summer,
like fruit that refreshes us, like the brooks that satisfy our thirst,
like the birds that sing, like the breeze that carries our smoke away.
What we like is hunting.
Nobody like you is going to stop us.
No, listen to him. He's wise.
He always has good advice.
Yeah, you can do what he tells you, but I'm not listening.
Now look, either you respect Maestro and our laws, or you'll beat it out of our camp.
That's the best yet you've given me, Orzer.
Right then, we'll go.
We don't need you. We're going to find a better place to live.
Follow me.
Nobody can fight stupidity. No reasoning with men like that.
And they're always around.
Miss Chief, my foot slipped. That was all like this.
Super fantastic.
They up to. One is over there. The other one is over there. Pretty crazy way to hunt, if you ask me.
Genius. Massacre. Some got away, at least. Can't beat it. I'll bet that way they're animals. Let's take a look.
Team Chief. Foreigners. Kill them. He's been on. Tree, your ground ends there. Extend all the way to that.
Patients run out. I get angry. Many warriors found that out. Now, I'll say it once more. Get off our land.
You don't scare me. I am Chief Hunter, and I say our lands go to that tree.
You are a miserable worm, but a soaring eagle.
I am as cunning as the prairie fox, and eagles always come to ground.
When the eagle strikes, you die.
Disappeared the dun and the buffalo, but the great sloth, as well as our friends the horses and the camels and the armadillos and many thousands of animals.
Times have changed, my friends.
Today we must share our hunting grounds with many other men.
There's much less fruit than there used to be.
We still have our old friend the buffalo, but that's not enough.
I've racked my brain and I think I have found a solution.
You can see it down the river.
There are plants there that we can eat and it will mean we all have healthier diets.
I've also had an idea on how we can hunt the buffalo a lot better.
Look, by pulling this string, we should be able to...
Watch, it's easier to demonstrate.
Ow!
It may need a few refinements.
All the same, I have a feeling it's a great invention.
My invention works.
No, please, if you don't understand, we've made the invention of the millennium.
Begin shooting.
Drawing me nothing low.
A great weapon all the same.
Spirit of the buffalo make hunting good.
Our hunters give thanks.
Your flesh gives us our meat.
With your hide we make our shelters and warm clothes.
We use your horns to adorn our village and your tendons for bowstrings.
And with your bones we make sharp arrowheads.
We are your friends.
It is with respect that our arrows pierce your body.
don't see them great many we can't catch them before nightfall those through from here it's
too dangerous to a leg is broken don't worry i'll fix it don't get some hide strips and two spears
and clean the buffalo hide we'll make a stretcher doesn't forget the buffalo's heart here is your
heart brother buffalo we return it so you will be reborn one day and will come back last the great
herds of buffalo little by little were to disappear as the white hunters deliberately
exterminated them to deprive the Indians, for they had supplied the Indians with all their needs.
In 60 million buffalo, but by the end of the 19th century, only a few hundred were still alive.